janna is with us in orlando hey janna
what's up
hi thanks for taking my call sure how
can we help
um i have a real estate and money
question we
with my husband's job going mostly
remote we have the opportunity to move
back to kansas city which is our
hometown
from florida where we've been for about
three years and um
so moving back towards family and um we
have a paid for house here
and we've been without a mortgage for
about three and a half years so moving
back we feel like we have
options but we're having a hard time
narrowing it down whether it's going to
be
lake or by a few acres or even build is
on the list
we can't we can't quite decide um
so we're trying to decide now if we
should just
buy what's on the market when it's time
or give it some time
and rent in the meantime so we can
have i don't know just experience the
process moving to florida we
i didn't even see my house before we
moved into it it was a little bit more
of a quick thing and it worked out and
it was great but
i kind of want to enjoy the process this
time but
we're we're going back and forth whether
that's worth it or not do we
take our time and rent and spend that
money that we haven't had to spend each
month or
go ahead and buy and deal with that
you could never go wrong with the lake
but i
i agree i agree but they're not as easy
to come by yeah but anyway
uh uh well here's the thing uh how long
have you been going
we've been done three years okay so you
know the market still you know
which neighborhood is which you kind of
know i don't want to be over there i do
want to be over there
that kind of we know the county that we
want to be in we know we have it narrow
down to certain areas certain lakes
certain country areas
if you don't find the thing that you
want in those areas then it would be
rent and patience until you find the
thing you want
but if you find the thing you want
there's no rule that says you have to
not get it right right
i hear in your voice a very i hear in
your voice a very
kind way usage of the word we
what what's you know this place is where
you're from what's the hank what's the
hold up
um my husband is real decisive and i'm
real not
yes and i think he'd be okay
yeah because i'm that way i can make a
decision if i don't like it i'll just
make another decision meanwhile sharon's
still thinking
yep yep that's kind of how we are
and i kind of want i i was okay with
that on the way here because
i was excited to come and all i wanted
was a pool in florida well
you're going to buy as you move
it needs to go at a slow enough pace
that you
process it you not him because we
already know he can process it
but that you process it in a way that it
involves enjoyment
pleasure this is a time of your life
you've earned the right to pay cash for
property because you're moving from a
paid for property
you know the area this should be a
pleasurable
by and large moving never completely but
i mean it's like a root canal but
a pleasurable a pleasurable process for
you if you feel rushed
jammed pushed hustled frustrated
chill just rent yeah but if you found
the right thing
and you had the appropriate number of
hours or days to
emotionally process it while you were
making an offer then there's no
limitation right and we we're still
holding out hope that there's going to
be that place that we both get excited
about whether it's
lake or land well guys this is it my
guess is you're gonna rent and it's
gonna take a while because you're on a
bit of a treasure hunt
a little bit yeah so then my question is
um what i mean in that kind of a
situation
most places like to have a year lease
and
how much would we then i mean we could
spend whatever we want i guess on rent
but we don't want to waste our money
so then how do you determine how much
rent you are spending money to buy
patients
right so how much is how much is it
worth to you
that's what the question you got to ask
you maybe you want to negotiate with the
landlord up front that says hey if we
find another place
and we can find you a replacement tenant
you'll agree to release us
okay something like that as a landlord i
i happily will release any tenant early
from a lease if i have a replacement
okay because i often can increase the
rent when they leave so i love
replacements
okay yeah and i haven't looked into
specific rentals so maybe i need to
explore that a little bit more that's
not going to happen with a corporate
rental like the apartment complex that's
managed out of atlanta or some such crap
right
but mom and pop like me that's got a
house over here with a
rent sign from walmart in the front yard
they'll do all kinds of deals with them
as long as it makes sense for them
right so i guess we just need to decide
what size of a house because it's going
to go anywhere from a four bedroom for
1800 a month to a
two bedroom which would be cramped with
our two kids it's closer to twelve
hundred
the money stop the whining about the
money you've got the money
you're trying to create a process here
that i mean you're millionaires okay
i can feel it i know the numbers i know
i know the vibe on this so
you're there so just enjoy you're gonna
blow
15 20 000 bucks for patience
to get the right property and that's
what you're going to spend on rent for a
year
while you just sit there and enjoy the
process of finding the right property
getting the land bought
you may even extend the release a little
bit while you build the house that's
right
so just just do it at a pace there's no
you know one of the things money gives
you is margin it gives you wiggle room
and you've got the money to have wiggle
room without forcing yourself anyway
you know and but when you're broke it's
always you know you're just pushed in
the corner
and uh god i hate that feeling because
right about the time i do that's when i
do something stupid
every time i do something stupid when
that happens that's right yeah i have
that pressure that i'm jammed up
i mean i can't tell you how many times
somebody said well the car broke down so
i bought a new car
you know it's like what when you just
fix your freaking car
you know but it broke down they just
break down all the time you know it's
it's that same thing that's going on is
that but they're
you know the the hassle of fixing a 500
thing on a car when you're broke is a
big freaking deal
well in our house we're not broke and
just a couple of days ago my wife said
hey we got to fix a seat belt we could
still have a child seat back there we
got to fix a seat belt
and the first words out of my mouth were
is it just time for us to get a new car
yeah that one's been there a while
and she said i mean while you're on the
show they'd be nice
and so i started thinking through and
talking i got to be on the show with
dave i can't
well i mean it's just it's just what you
said it's like
or yeah 300 bucks solves the seat belt
problem
and i mean it's just how quick it was
well
clearly we need to throw this thing in
the lake and start her question was a
really good question
it is but that doesn't sound like a
money issue to me no it's it's a process
it is a
heart it's a process issue he makes
decisions real fast and he's jammed her
up before
hmm forced her in i know this because
i've done it to my wife for 38 years
and if this is going to be the forever
house which doesn't exist but this is
going to be it
there's no forever house i want to do
slow go slow and make my dream house
until your freaking dream changes okay
so shut up you don't there's no such
thing it's a house let's go buy it